hey guys Pete here as you probably know
there is no new episode of Twin Peaks
this coming weekend so I wanted to do a
short video today about something that's
been on my mind and then I wanted to
hear from you guys what you'd like to
see in the week off
now of course I'll do my regular videos
of 10 things you might have missed in
part 8 and I have some Q&A s to catch up
on but I'd like to delve into some
theory videos and I'm open to
suggestions about what you guys want to
see so the thing that has been bothering
me since part two aired and I've been
thinking about and I can't figure out
why we're not talking about it and by we
I mean I just haven't seen any post
about it on any of the forums I haven't
really if I had searched I haven't
really been able to find anybody else
who's asked any questions about it and
it has to do with ha in part 2 which was
titled the Stars turn and a time
presents itself
we saw the deputy chief Hawk was in the
Twin Peaks Sheriff's Department he had
pulled out some old boxes that had
information about agent Cooper based on
a lead he got in part one from Margaret
Lanterman the log lady so in part two
he's there and Andy and Lucy come in and
he tells them to get all the information
from downstairs and to meet him in the
conference room the next morning after
he leaves the next thing we see him do
is he's walking through the wood to
Glastonbury Grove as he's walking the
log lady calls him again on a cell phone
and she asked him where he's going he
said that he is on the same page as her
log again or something along those lines
and that something is about to happen or
something is supposed to happen and he
walked up and we see him approach the
circle of sycamore trees he flashes his
flashlight on them and then we see
either red curtains come in from there
it cuts to the scene of Cooper our first
shot of Cooper back in the lodge where
he's talking to Mike and then Laura
eventually comes but we never hear
anything about Hawks trip to Glastonbury
Grove again in fact there have been
several chances for him to bring this
out
especially in part seven when he talks
about that place you know he's talking
about the portal he's talking about how
Cooper had crossed into that with an e
and come back and how it was no longer
probably the good Cooper that came out
but he never mentions the fact that he
was just there and if he saw anything or
if anything happened so if you don't
remember I mean I'm sure you remember if
you've ever watched the original series
of Twin Peaks and you remember the final
episode where we got all this red room
stuff you know from Cooper and Annie and
when the Merrill but why would it not be
important
whatever happened to hawk there or why
is he holding it back from telling other
people about his trip there we haven't
seen the log lady sense part two and I'm
not sure how limited her screen time
will be throughout this season but we
have seen like with Col rod we've seen
that he can see when the boy is killed
by the traffic he can see the yellow
light that leaves the boy's body and you
know some people think that's gone on
Bossier and some think it is the spirit
but either way we can see that those two
people call rod and vlog lady were
abducted together and they both clearly
have for lack of a better term like some
sort of extra sense or super power if
you want to call it that I've mentioned
in several of my videos that it's cool
that Hawk is the person that has been
presented with this kind of stuff
because he believes in the lodges in the
past Hawk has said that you know his
people believe that the White Lodge is
where the people who rule man in nature
reside he's mentioned passing through
the Black Lodge in order to emerge on
the other side things like this so so
this otherworldly place her places is
not something that's foreign to him he
you know he believes that there are
these lodges and he obviously isn't as
skeptical about the log lady as other
people are so that's what happened I
mean we speculated quite a bit on the
first statement the log lady gave us
about hawk about his heritage and
something's missing but I just haven't
seen a lot of conversation about this so
I want to know what you guys think do
you think he saw something there just to
give a quick recap of the timeline we
know that agent Cooper switched with
dougie the next day after hawk would
have been there at night but if you
think about it when he entered the box
the glass box in New York it was
nighttime there so those two things
could have been happened simultaneously
but why would hawk not why with him
being at the at the portal to not have
anything significant that we found out
about yet so yeah you see where I'm at
I'd like to know what you think I'll be
doing some kind of video tomorrow
probably a Q&A or the 10 things you
might have missed so in the meantime
please leave comments about what you
think about this or what else you want
to know about the ongoing mysteries in
season 3 and make sure you like the
video subscribe to my channel and thanks
for watching I'll talk to you soon